وفي حين اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه عن
رصد ما قالت انه منطاد تجسس صيني اخر يحلق
فوق امريكا اللاتينيه يتوجه المنطادو
الصيني الاول نحو الساحل الشرقي للولايات
المتحده
ونقلت قناه اي بي سي عن مسؤول امريكي قوله
ان السلطات تدرس انتظار مرور المنطاد فوق
المحيط الاطلسي لاسقاطه وقال المسؤول انهم
من المرجح ان تضطر السلطاته الى اغلاق
المجال الجوي المحلي وعلى مساحه كبيره من
اجل حمايه المداريين بينما تحاول اسقاط
المنطاد وانها تعمل على خطط ليهبط في
المياه الاقليميه الامريكيه واضاف ان
بلاده تريد الاحتفاظ بالمنطاد لدراسته
في هذه الاثناء تدعو الصين الى تعامل حذر
وهادئ لحل قضيه المنطاد وقال مدير مكتبي
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه الصيني
انه يتعين على بلادي والولايات المتحده
الحفاظ على تركيزهما والتواصل في الوقت
المناسب اضافه في اتصال هاتفي الى الجمعه
مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه عن طلب ليكن
انه يجب على البلدين تجنب سوء التقدير
وحسن اداره الخلافات في مواجهه المواقف
غير المتوقعه بحسب ما نقلته وكالته